un peu partout dans le monde on constate
un recul du droit et de l'accès à
l'avortement
impossible au canada c'est intéressant
de voir à quel point ce thème s'est
invitée dans la campagne électorale
et vous allez voir qu'il ya des gens qui
travaillent très fort et avec de
nouvelles stratégies pour que ça reste à
l'agenda
[Musique]
à votre vie au canada jusqu'à combien de
semaines on a le droit de se faire
avorter
côté simone questions j'imagine
mais dix semaines quels sont tes
schiesser 4,5
j'imagine également quatre doigts
jusqu'à la fin c'est vrai quoi je pense
c'est trois mois peut-être quatre mois
c'est monsieur qui a raison depuis que
l'avortement a été légalisé au canada en
1988 il n'y a pas de loi qui réglemente
la pratique de l'avortement mais cela
peu de canadiens le savent je sais pas
ce moment douté aux grues
oui tout à fait c'est réglementé
ouais ça ne sais pas ce que ça nous
étonnerait d'apprentis n'y a aucune loi
qui encadre l'avortement et ça
m'étonnerait
nous sommes la seule démocratie au monde
qui n'a pas de loi sur l'avortement une
nouvelle génération de militants
anti-avortement montent aux barricades
ils sont passionnés cris vraiment neuf
la politique m'intéresse depuis que j'ai
10 ans ils sont éduqués
il ya des jeunes qui choisissent la
profession dans le but de travailler
pour le mouvement pro et ils savent
parler aux jeunes au coeur de leur
stratégie
l'humour a remplacé les images de foetus
ensanglanté avec un site web ça peut
être sauvé pikachu points comme c'est
tout con quoi mais en fait ça a fait 3
millions vu dans les médias
c'est un mouvement moderne jeune
dynamique et donc est porteur d'idées
ce qu'ils sont capables de faire avec le
peu de ressources relatives qu'ils ont
ce 7e temps leur but être la génération
qui fera reculer
l'accès à l'avortement samus charaf et
le plus jeune député dans l'histoire du
parlement ontarien
il a été élu en 2016 en partie grâce à
l'aide de rightnow c'était deux ans
avant l'élection de son chef le premier
ministre dr est la seule organisation
politique canadienne qui se concentre
sur la nomination et l'élection de
politiciens pro vie au provincial et au
fédéral
quant à word et cofondateur de rightnow
l'organisation identifié des gens qui
s'opposent à l'avortement et les
encourage à devenir candidat il disait
dans street a gagné leur élection est un
des premiers d'une minute candidats qui
seront élus dans nos parlements en
incitant les électeurs anti avortement à
devenir membres des partis politiques
right now estime avoir contribué à la
nomination de enjoy scheer à la tête du
parti conservateur et à celle des
premiers ministres d'oxford en ontario
jason kenny en alberta et scott clos en
saskatchewan
mon nom et alyssa je suis co fondatrice
et directrice de rightnow à l'esad olobe
explique à des bénévoles comment faire
du porte à porte
pourquoi faire du porte à porte pour les
chiffres et l' influence selon right now
il y avait une cinquantaine de députés
anti avortement à la dissolution du
parlement il ya quelques semaines
l'organisation en veut
cent soixante dix pour avoir une
majorité de sièges
notre but est de réduire le nombre
d'avortements entre autres en faisant
adopter des lois
et pour y parvenir on a besoin d'une
majorité au parlement pour l'élection
2019 right now vis de faire élire 50
nouveaux députés anti avortement on ne
va pas faire élire 120 députés d'un
conte chant est ce qu'un texte ça va
prendre plusieurs élections pour y
arriver le travail de capital commence
là où celui de right now fini elle est
conseillère légal et lobbyiste pour
l'organisation antiavortement winnie de
là en français on a besoin d'une loi
prévoit la plupart des pays ont des lois
qui protègent les enfants en ont encore
nés à partir d'un certain stade en
espagne par exemple
la loi autorise l'avortement jusqu'à 16
semaines seulement
sauf en cas de danger pour la femme ou
d'anomalies graves du foetus en france
en allemagne en irlande
ces quatorze semaines en suisse 12
semaines dans beaucoup de pays d'europe
les lois ont en général trois
composantes une limite gestationnel un
délai de réflexion et une rencontre de
canso ligne obligatoire au canada il
n'ya pas de loi mais il ya tout de même
des lignes directrices l'association
médicale canadienne indiquent qu'à
partir du moment où le foetus est viable
autour de 22 24 semaines
il faut des circonstances
exceptionnelles pour que l'avortement
soit indiquée pour les militants anti
avortement
ce n'est pas ainsi
ça ne sont que des lignes directrices
rien de plus il n'y a pas de
répercussions si un médecin ne les
respectent pas chaque année au canada
cent mille enfants perdent la vie à
cause d'un avortement c 300 enfants
chaque jour au canada une grossesse sur
six se termine par un avortement tabitha
your heart et ses collègues ont écrit un
projet de loi pour réduire le nombre
d'avortements
il prévoit une limite après semaine de
gestation un délai de réflexion de 48
heures et une rencontre de consulting
obligatoire pendant que certains
militants s'activent sur les franges
juridiques et politiques d'autres
s'occupe du volet éducatif
cet enfant allait être pauvre on l'a tué
juste à temps elle est bien mieux morte
j'essaie
[Musique]
laura classe elle est une actrice de
toronto elle produit des vidéo
anti-avortement qui ridiculise les
principes fondamentaux du mouvement pro
choix
on reçoit des messages de gens qui sont
très fâchés parce qu'on est anti
avortement et qu'ils sont pro avortement
mais à cause de nos vidéos
certains nous reviennent et disent ok
vous m'avez vraiment fait réfléchir
tiens tant nos droits humains la magie
du canal génitales la vidéo la plus
populaire de laura klassen aurait été
vue des millions de fois
elle dénonce le fait qu'au canada un
foetus n'a aucun droit avant de sortir
du ventre de sa mère
à bien observer pas un humain par un
humain on arrive à la sortie un humain
madame klassen et la militante la plus
radicale que nous avons rencontré celui
là est le produit d'un viol suis désolé
c'est celui là peut-être celui-là
respect swan je ne sais plus ils sont
tous pareils
elle est contre l'avortement même en cas
de viol
ce n'est pas radical de dire qu'il ne
faut pas tuer les gens l'avortement est
mal parce qu'il tue n'importe comment
l'être humain et et concision
pau trop beau trop occupés trop chaud
meurtre pas nous retrouvons est trop
vieux trop seul gros risque trop grand
trop laid trop petit pour avoir cette
enfant
en europe aussi le mouvement anti
avortement a changé de registre
somme
les survivants
émile du port et le porte-parole du
groupe entier avortement français les
survivants le sigle de son groupe fait
référence au fait qu'en france il y à un
avortement pour quatre naissances
l'idée c'est qu'on a cinq doigts de la
main est en fait en retranchant ce
douala et bien on montre que finalement
on avait une chance sur cinq de ne pas
naître et c'est une sorte de doigt
d'honneur mais mais plus respectables
quoi je suis unique et irremplaçable
pour mobiliser les jeunes aimé du port a
révolutionné la façon dont on parle
d'avortement par exemple mon premier
happening géant tout récent jeunes avec
un plastique autocollants conforme vert
et j'en ai mis un cinquième enrubanné
dans un plastique rouge non conformes
le but des survivants n'est pas
d'éliminer l'avortement c'est de cesser
de le banaliser
notre but premier c'est surtout de
permettre aux gens de parler de l'ibg et
surtout bas est ce qu'on peut pas
trouver d'autres solutions et comment on
fait pour que ce mal ne soient plus
nécessaires plutôt que de glorifier
l'avortement comme un droit inaliénable
de la femme
toutes les méthodes sont bonnes pour
provoquer la discussion interruption
d'émissions de télévision en direct
placardage sauvage dans le métro de
paris campagne d'avortement de génie
avec les premiers selphy de gandhi
d'einstein et de bob marley en fait on a
beaucoup travaillé sur instagram snap
chatte et dans une moindre mesure
facebook est en fait on a développé du
snack compte est donc du contenu à
grignoter le gros succès des survivants
une application mobile mettant en
vedette pikachu un personnage de jeu
vidéo ultra populaire chez les jeunes et
journalistes sont dit oulala
ce gala est en train de toucher nos
jeunes net en train de court circuiter
finalement tous les réseaux médiatiques
pour imposer
ces opinions nauséabond ils sont
publicitaire actrice avocate comptable
ou activistes de carrière ils sont
déterminés mais réussiront-ils là où
leurs prédécesseurs ont échoué
[Musique]
richard frau aux états unis 43% des
femmes vivent dans des états qui sont
hostiles au droit à l'avortement elles
n'étaient que 7 % dans cette situation
il y a vingt ans life is running out
depuis quelques années plusieurs états
américains ont adopté des lois qui
interdisent l'avortement après ces
souris semaine en alabama on vient
d'adopter un projet de loi qui interdit
d'avorter même en cas de viol ou
d'inceste
les remises en question du droit à
l'avortement sont plus en plus frontale
sont plus en plus explicites direct
véronique pronovost prépare une thèse de
doctorat sur les stratégies des
mouvements anti avortement entre autres
aux états unis la stratégie est
l'étonnant c'est clairement le fait de
remettre en question l'arrêt de la cour
suprême roe contre wade qui avait
légalisé l'avortement en 73 au canada
c'est l'arrêt morgenthau qui a légalisé
l'avortement en 1988
auparavant seuls les avortements
recommandé par un comité de trois
médecins étaient autorisés selon la cour
cela portait atteinte au droit à la
sécurité des femmes
ils ont conclu que c'était appliqué de
façon arbitraire et injuste ça allait à
l'encontre de la charte canadienne des
droits
la cour suprême à décriminaliser
l'avortement mais elle a laissé une
grande porte ouverte c'est très fort ce
que dit le jugement
ça dit que c'est au parlement de se
pencher sur la question est est-ce
coistia
dans le texte de son jugement la cour
affirme que la charte canadienne des
droits permet de fixer des limites
raisonnables aux droits de la femme et
que l'intérêt qu'a l'état de protéger le
foetus justifierait l'imposition de
conditions à partir d'un certain stade
de développement
il s'agit là d'une brèche que les
militants d'aujourd'hui sont en train
d'exploiter de façon stratégique
le mouvement pro vie a changé de
stratégie
au lieu d'exiger l'interdiction totale
de l'avortement
on essaie de s'aligner sur ce que les
canadiens sont prêts à appuyer afin de
séduire les canadiens les militants ont
décidé de morceler leur objectif pour le
rendre plus digeste
ils font le pari que les canadiens
seront d'accord dans les rues de
montréal
nous avons constaté qu'ils ont peut-être
raison pour aux cornes l'avortement
après treize semaines de grossesse à peu
près trois mois contre cc maximum jouer
bon mais pas trop longtemps l'avortement
d'une adolescente de 15 ans et moins
sans le consentement des parents
quand tu rentres pas sans le
consentement de ce ballon une rencontre
de carling obligatoire avant d'avoir un
avortement
oui c'est important un délai de
réflexion obligatoire de deux jours
avant de procéder à un avortement pour
pour laissez pas la réflexion deux jours
je pense que c'est raisonnable
un sondage ipsos réalisé en 2017 révèle
que 36 % des canadiens sont d'accord
avec l'imposition de restrictions
ce qu'il faut comprendre c'est que ces
restrictions là c'est juste un début
c'est vraiment une mise en bouche une
introduction qui peut mener à une pente
glissante beaucoup plus importante
la stratégie des petits pas à
fonctionner dans certains pays d'europe
et rocard quand philippe robert garde et
la pologne
il était comme le canada il n'y avait
pratiquement pas de restriction à
l'avortement et grâce à des lois ils ont
lentement réduit le nombre d'avortements
le mouvement anti anti genre anti ivg en
europe a réussi à remettre en cause des
caisses des questions que nous pensions
était pacifiée dans plusieurs pays
depuis 20 ans nilda talent lutte pour
faire progresser les droits depuis
quelques années la nature de son travail
a changé
ça fait maintenant sept huit ans que un
pourcentage croissant de mon travail est
simplement de limiter les tentatives de
restreindre ses droits en 2018 la
pologne a restreint l'accès à la pilule
du lendemain en 2015
l'espagne a rendu le consentement
parental obligatoire pour les mineurs
au portugal les femmes doivent
maintenant se soumettre à un examen
psychologique pour obtenir un avortement
et celui ci n'est plus remboursé par
l'état
en hongrie la constitution a été
modifiée afin d'inclure la protection du
foetus dès le moment de la conception
avant je me disais moins pour que
européens canadiens on est plus
intelligent que les américains fin de
l'année se produire chez nous mais bon
voilà on n'est pas plus intelligent que
les américains aux états unis la cour
suprême vient d'accepter d'entendre une
cause à propos d'une loi qui limite de
façon draconienne l'accès à l'avortement
en louisiane
la présence de deux nouveaux juges
nommés par donald trump permet pour la
première fois aux militants
anti-avortement d'espérer une victoire
décisive contre le droit à l'avortement
au canada
l'activiste pro-choix just auteurs
pensent que la partie sera beaucoup plus
difficile
le gros avantage qu'on a au canada c'est
qu'il n'y a aucune restriction aucune
loi sur l'avortement alors il part de
zéro contrairement aux pays qui ont des
lois et qui n'ont qu'à les resserrer au
canada il faudrait faire adopter une
toute nouvelle loi d'abord au parlement
ensuite au sénat ultime mans cette loi
pourrait être contestées jusqu'en cour
suprême où elle devrait faire l'objet
d'un jugement favorable des batailles
comme celle là ça fait 30 ans qu'on
emmène les pro choix ont toujours été du
côté des vainqueurs et les anti choix du
côté des perdants qu'habitant joueurs je
pense que le vin est sur le point de
tourner ici on a parlé d'avortement
constamment pendant la campagne
électorale
la question préoccupe beaucoup les
canadiens
pour progresser les militants doivent
faire migrer l'opinion publique vers
leur point de vue pour cela il mis sur
l'information
certains disent sur la désinformation
le canada est le seul pays qui ne
protège pas les bébés l'avortement peut
se faire n'importe quand peu importe la
raison
n'importe quand pour n'importe quelle
raison dans sa vidéo ou unis de leur
fais comme si les lignes directrices des
associations médicales n'existait pas on
va tabler sur le fait que baïocco de loi
au canada
et comme si c'était le far west de
l'avortement ce pauvre est ce une fois
ouais c'est pas vrai que cette absence
de loi le fait en sorte qu'ils ont fait
ce qu'on veut entendre d'avortement %
des avortements surviennent après le
premier trimestre c'est plus de 15 mille
bébés par année encore ici winnie de la
exagère il n'y a pas de statistiques
globales pour l'ensemble du pays pour
arriver au chiffre de 15 milles
l'organisation s'est livré à une
généralisation de statistiques
partielles qui ne tient pas la route
même chose quand elle écrit qu'il y à
2500 avortements après 20 semaines
chaque année au canada
selon nos calculs il y en aurait moins
de 1000 est tellement les anti choix et
cette faire peur d'entretenir des mythes
qui rabaisse les femmes et insultent les
médecins
pour jeff carter comme pour neil data en
europe
au delà des apparences et des stratégies
le mouvement anti avortement
d'aujourd'hui n'est pas très différent
de celui d'hier comprend du vieilles
idées religieuses
on aimait dans un tremplin lave-linge
laïcisant et on en ressort avec quelque
chose qui ressemble à du langage des
droits humains ou a demandé en fait ils
veulent renvoyer les femmes aux rôles
traditionnels d'épousé et de mère ne
crois pas ce succès potentiel du
mouvement anti avortement 2.0 le
mouvement anti avortement au canada a
gagné en assurance
avec un potentiel gouvernement indien
chez eux ils ont l'impression que c'est
leur tour qu'ils vont être capables de
faire adopter des lois
je pense que leurs attentes ne sont pas
réalistes même l'arrivée de right now
dans l'arène politique ne l'inquiète pas
gold
ils sont très bons pour faire élire des
candidats dans les circonscriptions
mais dans tous les cas quand ces
candidats sont devenu premier ministre
ou chef de parti ils n'ont rien fait à
propos de l'avortement
j'ai fait un engagement que je vais
voter contre
à n'importe quelle mesure la culture et
les lois si l'on a changé mais je vous
rassure les canadiens sont en train de
changer d'opinion sur l'avortement le
monde sera ébranlée de constater le
succès que nous aurons au canada au
cours des dix prochaines années
ce qui m'inquiète c'est cette fameuse
pente glissante donc cette le fait qu'on
soit en train de consolider une lettre
en place tous les facteurs qui ont mené
à la fenêtre d'opportunité aux états
unis qui se paie rien qui vient empêcher
l'établissement ces facteurs le
benzaclin d'opportunités le temps qu'à
moi il est très possible que se rouvrir
dans les années dans dix ans dans 15 ans
dans 20 ans on se fait peur que ça pue
ça
[Musique]
je